Morphology with complex SEs
Previously we have looked at using mathematical
morphology and the structuring in the elements
that we used were either squares or rectangles
and we showed how we could use morphological
processing technique to select particular
shapes out of an input image. We could use
a square structuring element and we would
select only the squares from the input image
when we can eliminate rectangles and vice
versa.
Let's now consider the problem where we want
to find shapes that are not just squares or
rectangles. Mathematical morphology allows
us to do this but we need to make some small
adjustments to the technique that we talked
about previously.
Let's consider now the problem of trying to
find the diagonal line segments in this particular
image. So we want a structuring element that
will select these shapes here shown in red
or alternatively we might want to find all
the shapes that are a diagonal line but in
the opposite direction.
In the most general case, we should be able
to select a line at any particular angle.
In order to be able to do this, we need to
change a definition of the structuring element.
We are going to allow the cells within the
structuring element to have the possible value
which is don't care.
That means they are not taken into account
when we perform the morphological processing.
We consider that those cell elements can have
a value of zero which means they are not considered
to be part of the structuring element or they
can have the value of one which means they
are considered to be part of the structuring
element.
Let's consider a simple example. Here we have
a low resolution example image which contains
two lines which slope upwards from left to
right, another diagonal line which slopes
downward from left to right and a vertical
line. We are going to choose a three by three
structuring element which will select the
diagonal lines which slope upwards looked
at from left to right.
I am going to show another one of the animations
that we have looked at previously and it's
going to show the mathematical morphology
process in practice.
Once again we see the active elements in our
structuring element are coloured red and as
they move across the image, the result will
only be true if the three red elements in
the structuring element lay across pixels
which are all set or have a value of true.
As the structuring element moves across we
see that our output image contains line segments
which slope upwards from left to right. Clearly
I can flip that structuring element around
and I will be able to select lines which slope
downwards when looked at from left to right.
Once again we have this notion of keeping
or retaining only those elements of the image
which are compatible with the structuring
element. Here is our original image, the input
image. This is the result of the mathematical
erosion process.
In this example, the structuring element was
a three by three matrix but only the elements
on the diagonal of that three by three matrix
took part in the morphological processing.
The rest of them were set to the don't care
value and they did not participate.
Let's introduce a real example here. I am
going to load an image of a tomato and this
is an image that we have seen previously and
on the way in I am going to gamma correct
the image. And I am assuming that the image
was gamma encoded with a gamma value of 2.2.
Let's just display the image, see what it
looks like and there we have it. Now I want
to find just the red pixels. I want to identify
just the tomato fruit and to do that I am
going to use a toolbox function, which performs
a kmeans classification, I will explain that in a moment.
It has three output arguments and the function
colorkmeans and I parse in the image and the
next argument that I pass in are the number
of different colors that I want the scene
classified into. And I am going to tell that
there are four colors in this particular image.
This looks to me that clearly a bunch of red
pixels, there is a bunch of green pixels,
there is a bunch of quite dark background
pixels and then there is also some lightish
pixels, So I am going to tell it to do it's
best effort at trying to segment those pixels
into four unique classes.
The result then is our three matrices. One
of the matrices is the variable CLS or class
and it is a double position image just the
same size as the input image. It's 238 pixels
high by 318 pixels wide.
Then we can have a look at the class image.
Create a new figure and I will display the
matrix CLS class and here it is. And what
we see is it looks quite posturized.
If I click on some values here we see that
the red tomato fruit pixels have been classified
with a value of three.
So all of the red pixels have been assigned
to belong to class 3. This dark background
has been assigned class 4, which appears quite
bright actually. This background down here
has been classified as belonging to class
one and a lot of the green material has been
classified as belonging to class two.
This algorithm has got a random initialization
in it so every time you run it you get a different
class assignment but in this particular run
the important thing to remember is that the
tomato colored pixels have all been assigned
to class number 3. I can create now a binary
image all pixels that belong to class 3 and
I can display that image.
This is a binary image the pixels with a zero
for the background on that tomato and 1 if
the do belong to the tomato. We can clearly
see here that the fruit are not complete.
The bottom fruit has got a couple of holes
in it and this is because we are seeing a
reflection of an overhead light is being reflected
off the shiny skin of the fruit.
The other fruit has got reflections but it's
also partly obscured by some leaves.
One of them looks like a round object which
is what we would expect if for instance we
were building a tomato harvesting robot we
would for round red things the second fruit
isn't very round at all. So we can use some
morphological processing operations to patch
the holes in these fruit.
Let's get some idea about how big the holes
are. I am going to zoom in on this part of
the fruit here. Now we can see that they go
from about 80 to 105 so there almost 25 pixels
wide this particular hole in the fruit.
If I am going to have a structuring element,
I am going to perform a morphological closing
operation, it needs to be a very large kernal.
Let's perform a morphological closing operation
on this binary image. I will call the result
closed and I will use the iclose function
I am going to parse in the binary image of
the tomato and I am going to pass in a square
structuring element that's 15 pixels by 15
pixels. And I am going to compute that.
Now let me display that particular image.
Here we see that it has certainly it has patched
the holes in the bottom fruit and it's done
something to the top fruit. But we see it's
introduced quite a lot of jagged edges let's
have a look in here and we can see that it's
introduced some quite big steps into the shape
of the fruit.
The reason for this is we use the structuring
element that was a square 15 by 15 pixels
square. The fruit that we are interested in
we know is round so we could use an alternative
structuring element which is a circle and
I can use the toolbox function kcircle and
I am going to create a circle with a radius
of 15 pixels and I can display that. And here
is a structuring element that is a disk that
has got a radius of 15 and it sits within
a 31 by 31 matrix.
If I consider this matrix as the structuring
element, then the white pixels that are shown
here are part of the structuring element itself
and the black or zero value pixels are not
part of the structuring element.
What I have done now is created a structuring
element which is a circle or disk. It sits
within a square matrix. Let's apply this circular
structuring element to our image. So I am
going to compute the closure and parse in
the tomato image; the binary tomato image
and I parse in the round structuring element
and I will display that and we see now has
turned a slightly better job of patching up
the hole in a fruit.